a postcard setting that could deliver
Angela Merkel a political black eye
this is her home constituency in
Mecklenburg West Pomerania and this is
the right-wing populist who could win
the local parliamentary seat
he's the alternative for Germany's top
candidate leaf Eric home the former
radio host hovers at the edge of her
campaign rally trying to pick off
supporters in the seaside resort of
Bin's Merkel arrives to jeers from a
small but noisy group of right-wing
hecklers they're holding the same images
leaf Eric home uses on his own website
no we didn't organize those but I won't
stop any member from voicing their
protest that's a normal part of the
democratic process the f DS
anti-immigrant euro skeptic stance
offers a stark contrast to Merkel and
the party has made a foray into even
trickier ground
AFD leader Alexander Gulen recently said
Germany should change the way it
remembers World War two if I understand
it correctly and I didn't see the whole
speech but the line that I heard was
related to the fact that German soldiers
too did indeed have military
achievements and that is something
taught in military academies also in the
u.s. an explanation that some in this
crowd just won't tolerate give young man
thunder I would like to give the young
man from the aft some advice first of
all he should read the speeches of his
fellow party members and listen I got
the sense you didn't even know what your
own people are saying that surprised me
a bit and secondly freedom is always the
freedom of those who think differently
that's your point I don't believe it
the AFD has found a bedrock of support
here in the former communist East its
economy still lags behind the rest of
Germany a touchy subject the people here
in the former East are never satisfied
they're the ones who then shout down
Merkel go and see for yourself
cooking I think that's way out of line I
grew up here what you say is rubbish it
wasn't all that bad
of course many things were but not
everything really irony Alice man
tensions between east and west remain
despite large-scale investments like the
nearby aquarium exploiting those
divisions is part of the AFD strategy
says the conservative opposition if I
comfort of the a of these campaign is in
my view very much focused on trying to
divide society by dongja by its a few
and often the AFT is all about playing
different groups against each other the
big question here is how much stronger
the AFD can get in a region where it has
already become a mainstream force and
how much damage and AFD win here could
do to miracle on the national stage